hey guys just a very quick reminder
if you watch what's going on in the news
listen to people just see actually
what's going on
it's pretty overwhelming there's
Darkness all over the place
and if you listen to your emotions and
other people in the news you will feel
depressed and and man almost feel like
man I
oh
you can't do anything
but don't fall for that trick of Satan
because he who is in you is stronger
than he who is in the world remember
you have also received the Holy Spirit
The Light of Christ that's why Jesus is
called the Bright Morning Star because
he brought light into this world and he
has already overcome this world I
actually have this shirt on today the
lion of Judah
and that is exactly who you have in your
corner you're not alone in this Jesus is
with you until the end of the age
remember that always I love you guys see
you in the next video bye